You didn't see that coming
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new spider-man kraven video you did not see
this coming aaron taylor johnson as
the kraven of the spider-man and venom
movies we have our next big sinister six
character i'll explain what this means
i know there are a lot of questions about how this
affects him coming back as mcu quicksilver now too
but if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's so much
spider-man stuff happening in the next year and
we're supposed to get that spider-man 3 no way
home trailer pretty soon too so i'll explain that
at the end of the video as well just waiting for
tom holland to leak all that footage in the next
couple of weeks but you all probably saw the news
aaron taylor johnson is going to be the new kraven
of the related spider-man movies you have the mcu
spider-man movies with tom holland you have all
the venom movies and the spin-offs that sony are
doing and then obviously the crossover movies
with tom holland coming into the venom in other
spin-off films sony already confirmed a long time
ago that they were putting together an mcu version
of the sinister six kraven the hunter is just the
next og member of that roster i cannot wait for
him to show up so that we can all start doing more
evan peters quicksilver Wandavision memes and you
all probably remember the kick-ass reference from
wandavision yeah kick ass i feel the need for me
kick ass you know don't worry about it rumors
don't mean we know the truth right yeah yeah and
who knows buddy this might even get you laid if
you don't remember both aaron taylor johnson and
evan peters were in kick-ass long before either
one of them were playing versions of quicksilver
in avengers age of ultron in x-men days of future
past that's how old that movie is once his version
of kraven shows up the memes are going to be off
the charts i'm sure there's a deadpool timelines
joke in this somewhere too when all the hollywood
trades were breaking this news yesterday they
reported that they also went to keanu reeves in
adam driver for the role but as you can see both
of them turned it down keanu reeves kraven would
have been really cool but i'm assuming he probably
didn't want to sign a six picture deal like sign
himself up for a giant franchise without being
able to read all those movie scripts and kraven
probably felt a little too much like his john
wick character but here's what's going on with
kraven inside the marvel spider-man universe so
aaron taylor johnson was cast for the kraven solo
movie that sony is making right now obviously with
the intention that he would cross over with other
sinister sick stuff in the future right now the
reporting that the kraven movie is based on the
story of kraven's last hunt from the comics is
probably the best spider-man kraven story of all
time so it's not a bad place for that to pull from
even though they'll have to change some of the
story and plot because in the comics it's meant to
be kraven's actual last hunt where he accomplishes
his ultimate goal of hunting down spider-man
his greatest foe as he sees it defeating him
which he does successfully he doesn't kill him
and spider-man doesn't kill kraven but because
kraven accomplished everything that he set out to
do he feels like he has nothing left to accomplish
in this world and as spider-man swings off kraven
climbs into a casket and literally shoots himself
in the head and that's the end of the story
and this new kraven movie is meant to not only
tell his origin story but also be the beginning
of a new franchise and set him on the path to
crossover movies with spider-man venom the other
sony spider-man characters so because of the way
sony and marvel are working together they can do
more spider-man stuff inside the kraven movie now
like way more stuff than you saw of spider-man
references in the first venom movie that was
before sony and marvel's new sharing contract
imagine that first venom movie if there had been
more legit spider-man references during it that's
probably what the kraven movie is going to feel
like and if you didn't spot it last year there
were kraven easter eggs in some of these movies
already so when they were filming the morbius
movie on the set there were some trucks that
read kraven i mean it was very overt but they
were trying to reference here the rest of the
text on the trucks here just as kraven pastries
from the bronx in the new york city area like
gourmet meats this is obviously happening in the
new york city area where the morbius movie
takes place and where a lot of the venom 2
trailer footage takes place and apparently they're
implying the kraven runs a food service business
as cover for his hunting activities like the
ultra fresh gourmet deli meats he's selling are
from all the animals that he hunts but the kraven
truck was from the morbius movie more beast is a
venom spin-off so obviously they're all meant to
cross over the mta buses with the daily bugle logo
from the tobey maguire spider-man movies that
say where's spider-man those are also from the
morbius movie which isn't coming out till january
next year so we'll actually see venom 2 before we
see morbius but i think that they change things
a little so that the timeline makes sense all the
post-credits scenes make sense marvel did the same
thing with the mcu marvel phase 4 movies and all
the disney plus series because they had to shuffle
the order of some of the films but the daily bugle
logo in the morbius movie is the same version of
the toby logo from the venom 2 trailer recently
in 80 circus kind of tried to claim that venom
isn't aware of the existence of spider-man during
the venom 2 movie here's the clip of him talking
about that obviously there are links between venom
and spider spider-man in the marvel universe and
the spider-man story but in this you know we're
treating this very much as it hits his own world
the venom story is his own world there are nods
and and little moments that you just like this
newspaper the daily bugle of course but on on
the whole he's unaware they are unaware at this
point of other characters like spider-man that's
that's that's the way we've chosen to play this
particular episode of the of the of the movie
but well we'll wait and see we'll see what
what little uh things you can pick out of it
i'm not sure i totally believe him there but
we'll see there might just be a lot of spider-man
easter eggs and they discover the existence
of spider-man through the course of the film
i know it starts to get a little more confusing
when you talk about tom hall and spider-man like
which version of spider-man is supposed to exist
in this world and we're seeing so much of toby
maguire spider-man like it's even toby maguire's
costume inside the morbius movie the whole thing
with all this multiverse crossover crossovers that
kevin feige said that spider-man would be crossing
over cinematic universes in addition to traveling
the multiverse so it sounds like the sony people
will be allowed to reference whatever mcu stuff
they want to because you have mcu characters like
the vulture scorpion also showing up in morbius in
the other venomverse movies but we have the loki
series coming up that's going to be a multiverse
series with him traveling all over the timeline
through alternate realities as well so i think
that's meant to be the tutorial for hardcore
multiverse before we get to doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness in spider-man 3 which
will slowly ramp up the multiverse storytelling
so that by the time you get to doctor strange 2
you'll fully understand how all this works and for
the people that don't read comics it will actually
make sense why you have multiple different
versions of characters showing up together
on screen right now sony and marvel's sharing
contract just goes through spider-man 3 no way
home and then a crossover movie that they haven't
announced yet and i think that's going to be
doctor strange too multiverse of madness but the
president of sony pictures said that they would
renew their deal and they would do spider-man 4
with marvel but the renewal cycle that they're
on is sort of like a two movie deal like we'll
re-up for two movies then we'll sign another
deal for another two movies so on and so forth
until they decide to not do it anymore or until
disney finally just decides to buy sony outright
and get the spider-man character back but all we
know about is spider-man 4 after that is just
pure speculation like live-action miles morales
they've talked about doing live-action spider-man
into the spider-verse it sounds like spider-man 3
no way home is already kind of introducing some
spider-verse concepts but it does sound like the
live-action sinister six movie they're setting
up in the background that this version of aaron
taylor johnson kraven would be a part of will be
a sony production with kevin feige just producing
tangentially like he was a producer on the dl for
the first venom movie even even though it wasn't
a lot of publicity about that so even if some of
these big spider-man movies aren't made by marvel
marvel is still very much involved in them
being made right now in terms of that sinister
16 they're setting up the core members that we
have so far is we have michael keaton's vulture
character who we know is going to show up during
the morbius movie they just confirmed that alfred
molina is playing the original doctor octopus
from toby maguire's spider-man movie spider-man 2
which implies also that jamie foxx is probably
playing a version of his electro from the andrew
garfield amazing spider-man 2 movie we also have
the tinker we also have the shocker and we have
michael mando's scorpion character kraven is just
the latest piece in that team that they're putting
together but for those of you asking obviously
what happens to mcu quicksilver now so him
becoming kraven doesn't mean that he'll never come
back as the mcu version of quicksilver but the
safe bet is that we probably won't see him appear
in doctor strange too multiverse of madness as
quicksilver we know billy and tommy are supposed
to show up at some point during that and they will
be referencing other versions of mainstream
avengers characters that we've seen before
like alternate universe versions but they haven't
absolutely confirmed which characters those would
be if he does come back as mcu quicksilver
at some point i think it would probably be
for something really trippy and twisty like evan
peters quicksilver on Wandavision where you're
meant to question the nature of this reality
like he died they want him to stay dead but
there are a lot of ways you could explain scarlet
witch seeing visions of him again also hand in
hand with that evan peters did say he loved to
come back as legit x-men quicksilver in the mcu
but i don't expect that to happen anytime soon
when they start doing those core x-men characters
again like they're working on a new x-men movie i
think they just won't do quicksilver at all right
away and find some other way of bringing him back
into the universe in a bigger secret wars movie
where it actually makes sense that he's there
but all the other x-men characters are recast new
versions with different actors like i said it's
all about the multiverse that's why marvel phase 4
is treading so heavily on multiverse storytelling
the loki series is going to explain most of that
in really great detail i will be doing videos for
all those low-key episodes don't worry it's going
to start in a couple weeks and the way that
kevin feige actually talked about evan peters
quicksilver and aaron taylor johnson is that
they didn't do the evan peters version with the
intention of replacing mcu quicksilver they just
wanted to play into the idea of the false reality
of the hex of Wandavision is agatha the hardness
was gaslighting scarlet witch trying to get her to
mentally break so that she could steal her chaos
magic energy there were a whole bunch of deleted
scenes with his character doing quicksilver things
in the finale that they had to get rid of at the
last minute in a whole alternate ending i did a
video about that a couple months ago after the
finale so i had a link for that video in the
description down below and at the end of this
the brand new spider-man 3 no way home trailer
might get released sometime in the next week or so
tom holland's birthday is next week so i would
plan on them trying to do something around that
we'll just wait for him to leak all the
footage if they do wind up releasing it
of course i'll make a video for that and everyone
click here for my brand new eternals trailer video
for kit harrington's black knight character
in his future in the avengers movies and
click here to learn about all those Wandavision
quicksilver deleted scenes and alternate ending
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!